russlands präsident wladimir putin
unterzeichnet einen vertrag über
waffenlieferungen im umfang von mehr als
drei milliarden us-dollar mit dem
saudischen königshaus den bisher
stärksten verbündeten der usa im
arabischen raum und das ist kein
einzelfall
heute in vechta kompakt russlands
strategie im nahen osten und nordafrika
dass sie russland in syrien stark
engagiert ist hinlänglich bekannt sein
militärisches einschreiten hat eine
wende zugunsten von präsident assad
dabei geführt weniger bekannt ist dass
sich russland in der region ganz stark
engagiert starke allianzen geschmiedet
und dabei kommt ihm zugute dass es
einerseits auf alte beziehungen aus der
zeit des kalten krieges zurückgreifen
kann und andererseits hier ein rückzug
der usa dass ein gewisses vakuum
hinterlässt hin dass russland hineingeht
so bestehen heute schon wieder intensive
kontakte mit ägypten mit libyen mit
syrien selbstverständlich aber auch mit
dem iran mit saudi arabien und den nato
land türkei und der hisbollah im libanon
er stellt sich vielfach die frage welche
ziele russland bei diesem engagement
verfolgt welche absicht nist hat ganz
allgemein wird davon gesprochen dass
russland hier seine rolle als weltmacht
darstellen und festigen und ausbauen
möchte es möglich auf augenhöhe mit den
usa wahrgenommen werden darüber hinaus
wird immer wieder betont auch die gefahr
durch den islamistischen extremismus und
terrorismus
man darf nicht vergessen geschätzte 3000
kämpfer haben für den es in der region
gekämpft sie stammen aus russland und
die chance besteht dass sie zurückkommen
aber darüber hinaus gibt es auch sicher
andere absichten geopolitischer natur
russland hat hier in der region eine
ganz massive position die es zunehmend
ausbaut die einwirkungsmöglichkeiten vom
mittelmeer in den gesamten nahen osten
hinein ermöglicht rüstungs politischer
natur
wir haben heute die situation dass das
zweitgrößte volumen vom russischen
militärgütern in der region jetzt 36
prozent ein enormer absatzmarkt
energiepolitisch hier geht es darum dass
man sich einerseits mit den
ölproduzenten und gas
vor ort abstimmt preislicher natur aber
andererseits auch die abhängigkeit
europas erhalten kann indem man in
diesen ländern mitgestalten und
mitbestimmen kann
zusätzlich haben wir noch
wirtschaftspolitische aspekte hier geht
es darum investoren aus der regierung zu
gewinnen andererseits auch absatzmärkte
zu finden und ein hintergrund dabei ist
sich auch die sanktionen die der westen
gegenüber russland verhängt hat im
zusammenhang mit der creme annexion zu
umgehen oder zu mildern
russland geht dabei sehr energisch und
zielstrebig vor so hat es zum beispiel
mehrere verträge mit saudi arabien
abgeschlossen nicht nur energiepolitisch
und wirtschaftspolitische sondern auch
im rüstungsbereich
so soll mit russischer hilfe eine eigene
rüstungsindustrie in saudi arabien
aufgebaut werden es ist gelungen der
türkei s400 ganz moderne flieger ap
raketensysteme zu verkaufen und das
einen nato land und ganz wesentlich es
hat sich nachhaltig in syrien
positioniert in dem es abkommen hat über
die luft dafür und den marinestützpunkt
und das geht weit über 2050 hinaus
begünstigt wird das russische vorgehen
durch eine allgemeine verunsicherung in
den meisten arabischen staaten durch
eine orientierungslos wirkende türkei
durch einen starken iran als partner
durch ein vages zögerliches verhalten
der usa und durch eine irritierte saudi
arabien das nicht mehr weiß wie starke
sich noch auf den partner usa verlassen
kann hat sich damit das strategische
gleichgewicht in der region geändert ist
etwa die allianz zwischen saudi arabien
und den usa oder auch türkei und usa
mittlerweile schon obsolet das wäre viel
zu früh das zu sagen es gibt auch
gegenteilige hinweise weil ja saudi
arabien auch ein großes geschäft
abgeschlossen habe den usa im umfang von
110 milliarden im mai des heurigen
jahres und konkurrenz scheint die
situation zu beleben weil unmittelbar
nach bekanntwerden des abkommens über
den waffen vertrag mit saudi arabien und
russland
der us kongress eine waffenlieferung im
von 15 milliarden freigegeben den
lokalen akteuren vor ort kommt es
offensichtlich darauf an hier ein
bisschen mehrgleisig sein zu können
mehr autonomie mehr
entscheidungsfreiheit zu haben bei der
wahl der partner in der zukunft wie ist
der herr russlands verhalten zu bewerten
wie kann es weitergehen
eines ist klar es handelt sich um eine
nachhaltige strategie für die region wo
man möglichst viele partner einbinden
will
ob es erfolgreich ist hängt von anderen
faktoren auch nicht nur vom russischen
engagement
welche interessen verfolgen die akteure
vor ort welche entwicklungen wird es in
nächster zeit geben ist es möglich die
spannungen zwischen den vielen
verbündeten vor allem saudi arabien und
iran zu überbrücken und nicht zu
vergessen kommen die usa zurück werden
sie sich stärker engagieren und man
sollte auch china nicht außer acht
lassen dass sie bisher sehr
zurückgehalten hat